do you know the Michelangelo effect it's
a psychological effect that describes
how over time two people often in a
relationship will craft each other into
the idealized version of what they want
so I make you more like what I want and
you make me more like what you want and
I am happy to become more like what you
want and the reason it's called the
Michelangelo effect is you can imagine
Michelangelo looking at this huge block
of marble and from the outside it's Ruff
Hune but over time he chips away and
creates the statue of David so he sees
inside of something which isn't perfect
the Perfection that he wants and over
time is able to craft this thing out of
it